la primera audiencia en moscú no arrojó
grandes conclusiones y les dio un margen
de negociación a rusia e israel para
definir el futuro de la agencia judía en
suelo ruso la semana pasada el
ministerio de exteriores ruso presentó
una demanda pidiendo el cierre de la
organización semigubernamental que
facilita la inmigración de judíos a
israel alegando una violación de las
leyes de privacidad sin embargo los
jueces se limitaron a fijar una nueva
citación para el 19 de agosto dando un
plazo de tres semanas que puede ser
utilizado para llegar a un acuerdo que
permita asegurar la continuidad de la
agencia precisamente una delegación del
gobierno israelí se encuentra en moscú y
se espera que mantenga diversas
reuniones para acercar posiciones con
rusia la ministra de interior israelí
peninah está mano ya está se mostró
confiada en que incluso con algunos
ajustes el organismo podrá seguir
funcionando aunque no están claros los
motivos de rusia para solicitar la
clausura de la agencia judía algunos
analistas consideran que es una forma de
rechazo del kremlin a la condena que el
primer ministro israelí yair lapid hizo
contra la invasión rusa en ucrania el
propio lápiz indicó días atrás que el
cierre de la agencia judía podría dañar
las relaciones entre israel y rusia
aunque luego aclaró que buscan saldar el
tema mediante el diálogo israel y rusia
han construido una amistad por
conveniencia sobre todo en siria donde
fuerzas israelíes suelen atacar
posiciones de milicias iraníes obligadas
a teherán en coordinación con moscú un
aliado del régimen de bachar al asad